افاد مراسل الجزيره باستشهاد فلسطينيه
واصابه اخرين في قصف اسرائيلي استهدف منزل
مواطن فلسطيني في منطقه الزوايده وسط قطاع
غزه وانتشرت فرق الانقاذ جثمان شهيده وعدد
من الجرحى فيما لا يزال اخرون عالقين تحت
الركام هذا المنزل في منطقه الزوايده تم
قصفه عدد كبير من الاصابات هنا في هذا
المكان هذه المنطقه الخطره
التي يعني نسير بداخلها واستهداف
منزل في هذه اللحظات هذا المنزل غير مخلى
من السكان اعداد من الاصابات هنا في هذا
المكان المستهدف حث نسير في هذه
المنطقه الوعره للوصول الى المكان
المستهدف في اه في صبات في في
واحد في قاعدين لحط ايده ورا را
عدد من العالقين لازالوا تحت ركام هذا
المنزل يحاول هنا بعض المواطنون برفقه
طواقم الانقاض وطواقم الاسعاف
انتشال عالقين من تحت هذا
الركاب اداد كبيره من المصابين تم
انتشالهم من هذا المنزل
[موسيقى]
المستهدف لفوق لفوق اع الطريق اع الطريق ا
الطريق طلع طلع طلع
ام